-Our next guest is a talented
actor and musician who is
currently on
his "Mainstream Sellout" tour.
His new album, "Mainstream
Sellout (Life in Pink Deluxe)"
is available now. You can also
see his documentary,
"Machine Gun Kelly's
Life in Pink" on Hulu.
Let's take a look.
-This is 112th and Dove.
We always had these big dreams.
Ladies and gentlemen,
how are y'all feeling?
I like that energy.
[ Laughs ]
First music video I ever shot
was right there
in front of that ADM Deli.
I got a gun pulled on me right
here, and I was like,
"Are you going to do this with
my daughter in the car?"
-Please welcome back to the show
Machine Gun Kelly, everybody.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Welcome back to the show.
How are you?
-There are censors, right?
-Yeah, yeah.
-I feel like [bleep]
-Oh, no.
[ Laughter ]
Well, I know you did a sold-out
show at MSG last night.
Congratulations.
-Thanks, thanks.
-But last time you were here,
you'd just done the VMAs.
You'd hurt your hand at the VMAs
and you hurt yourself again
last night at MSG.
-Yeah, I almost -- I'm going to
start having doctors around me
every time I see Seth Meyers
on my schedule.
-Yeah, the night before.
So what happened last night?
-Um, you know, you know when you
clink a champagne glass with
a fork to kind of --
-To get people's attention
to start a toast?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Yeah, I didn't have a fork.
-Okay.
-So I just clinked it
on my head.
-Okay.
-Um...
-That's a -- You know, they call
that, you know what --
[ Laughter ]
In medicine, they call that
"asking for it."
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, so I had a serious case
of that last night.
-Yeah, yeah, you had a serious
case of -- How was it?
How was the show? Must be always
fun to perform in New York City.
-Ow, f-- Um, sorry.
I keep forgetting I have this,
but I'm a hand talker, so I --
-Oh, right. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-You know, my first music check
was from New York City.
It was -- I was the first rapper
to win amateur night
at the Apollo Theater in Harlem.
-Really?
-And it was for $45.
-That's a pretty --
I mean, it must have felt like
a million dollars at the time.
-Absolutely.
And I never cashed it.
I always just held on to it.
And I think --
Well, the only thing I said
the whole day was
"We're at the Garden.
We're at the Garden."
And, like, there's obviously --
you know, growing up,
I watched -- It's funny that
we have a documentary called
"Life in Pink" because we
watched "Fade to Black,"
which was Jay-Z's doc,
so much growing up.
And right before we did the
Garden, we got to -- Yeah.
-Yeah, the Empire State
Building.
This was pink last night
in honor of your album.
That's a pretty big deal when
they do the Empire State
Building.
They decided to do this before
they heard you're the kind of
guy who smashes a glass
against his own head.
[ Laughter ]
-Thank God I waited.
-Did you get to go hang out at
the -- Did you get to go
to the Empire State Building
for the lighting?
-I did, I did.
So they took me on a --
This is where everybody
kind of stops at.
And then they showed me
a secret ladder
that takes you right there.
-Really?
-Yeah.
-You were that high?
-Mm-hmm. Thank God I didn't have
a champagne glass up there.
[ Laughter ]
Excuse me! New York!
-So I want to ask about
"Mainstream Sellout."
That seems like, I don't know,
a bit of a provocative title.
How did you come up with that
as the title for your album?
-I think because I was trying to
be provocative.
-Yeah, okay.
[ Laughter ]
So I got it nailed?
-I kind of -- I'm -- I think
it was almost
like I'm just in on the joke.
-Yeah.
-I put an album out prior to
that was really successful
in a genre that wasn't
in the mainstream.
And, you know, I was known for
doing a different genre of music
as well.
So I think it just kind of --
Success breeds hate.
And I was kind of like...
"But I'm hilarious, so this is
the title of the new --"
[ Laughter ]
I was -- It was almost like...
You know when you shake hands
with -- when, like, you're
in competition with someone
and you shake hands
and you smile at them
and you know you won?
-Yeah, and then you shake it
for a super-long time.
-But then you just shake it
and you're just like...
-Yeah.
-Yeah, that was me.
-That was you.
-That was me with
all of the hate.
-You're talking about --
Here is your documentary
that I mentioned.
We talk about the fact that you
did sort of switch genres
and the documentary shows
your early roots doing hip-hop.
Then you've got,
you know, pop-punk.
You sort of move into
this different genre.
Do you feel -- You know, again,
you're still early
in your career.
Do you think you're going to
drift back
to different genres,
move on to a new genre?
Do you have any plans or do you
think it just sort of happens
organically when you sit down
to write new music?
-Well, I did buy an accordion.
-You did?
[ Laughter ]
So...
-I think that's pretty exciting.
You know, Steve Carell plays...
[ Laughter ]
Steve Carell plays fife.
And I feel like you get the two.
-Wow.
[ Applause ]
-I feel like there's no --
There's no mainstream
accordion-fife duo.
-Mm. Yeah, we're going
underground anyway.
We want to be more of
like a cult band.
-You got engaged.
-I did.
-You and your fiancée,
Megan Fox,
you gave each other tattoos.
-Mm-hmm.
-Now, obviously, you've received
a fair amount of tattoos
over the years.
Do you feel like you are
a good tattoo artist?
-Her skin's really so--
I felt that I --
Hers is kind of fading.
-Okay.
-Her on me, though, she dug it
in so deep that I think --
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, hers is fading because you
felt -- you felt for her.
Oh, you were very soft.
-And with mine, she was like,
"Oh, no, this is sticking."
[ Laughter ]
Yeah. No, we did get our
voodoo dolls tattooed on us.
-Oh, that's pretty good.
-Yeah.
Yeah, I mean, you know, it's
interesting 'cause we were
watching the "Pam and Tommy"
series.
I forgot that Mark Mahoney did
theirs, but Mark also did ours.
-Oh, you have the same tattoo
artist?
-Mm-hmm.
-Oh, that's pretty good.
-Hopefully don't end up
the same.
[ Laughter ]
Hopefully don't take after
all the paths that...
[ Laughter ]
-I feel like he's due
a winner at this point.
[ Laughter ]
Do you remember any of --
You know, in watching
the documentary, do you have
early rap lyrics,
like the first ones
you remember writing?
-Uh...
Yeah, but you know what?
You know when you're -- You know
when you're 13 and corny?
-Yeah.
-Yeah, like, I remember there
was -- I think there was one
where I like -- You know
how you know it's corny?
'Cause I used the word
Bud Light.
And you're like 13. You're also
like, "You've never --"
-You're like, "I know what
the coolest drink is."
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. It's so funny.
There's no mention of, like,
cool liquors or anything.
Like, "break out the Bud Light."
I don't know, dude, I don't
know. I just -- I remember that
being that, and I remember
seeing that notebook,
and I burned it and I was like,
"No one will ever know
that I've written
this terrible rhyme."
-Hey, man, it's always such
a pleasure to see you.
-Thanks, Seth.
-Congratulations on everything
and take care of yourself,
alright?
No more --
-I will.
-Thank you, my friend. You guys,
that's Machine Gun Kelly.
"Machine Gun Kelly's Life in
Pink" is streaming now on Hulu.
We'll be right back
with Ingrid Andress.